what was living in a monastery like it's
the best what is what are we talking
about like what it's just an empty room
with like a tiny single bed and a sheet
and a pillow and that's it that's it you
have to eat the same thing as everyone
what's the food like what is it very
plain cheap basic food which is you know
funny for someone like me because I'm
I'm I'm pretty particular about my diet
yeah you brought over like like 20
different
ingredients yeah so what was the like
day in the life of tall in a
monastery you wake up at 5:00 a.m. to
the bell and you go and meditate like
constantly so till bedtime other than
two meals what how are you sitting are
you in a group is there other people
there mhm and you're just sitting there
well if you're talking about the Zen
Monastery cuz I stayed in Zen mon
Montery um and I did a thing with that
um the guy was telling you about the
kind of uh the integral Zen thing where
he uses Ken Wilbur's work in combination
with Zen that that's a little bit
different because he does talks we talk
about things
um and that's very separate from the
monaster like the vidanta monasteries
I've stayed at which there's very little
meditation in in terms of sitting
silently instead we are meditating on
the scriptures like the upanishads and
we're like diving into that what were
the differences the takeaways from the
experiences the the two different the
integral one and
the uh the meditating on the
scriptures they're both
incredibly have been incredibly helpful
to me because the
Vidant
um anytime I go into my head about
something the the the answer is there
based on this
knowledge
and with the Zen Monastery it's like you
just got to put your your butt in the
seat and sit and wait and maybe
something will happen maybe it won't but
just keep sitting and it's very
disciplined
and you go through a lot your body is
purging a lot
there's there's a lot and you don't
necessarily the answers as to what is
happening and so I think for somebody
like me I need both I need to be in a
place where there's complete uncertainty
but complete discipline and just doing
the regimented thing and then there's
the me that feels very
satisfied from an analytical standpoint
understanding what's happening like what
what is the gross and the subtle body
and the you know like I want to
understand these things about what it is
to be a human so I I like them both
understand what it means to be a human
so that like having that patience and
just sitting with yourself helps you do
that
yes more so like the analysis part Al so
the anal the actual okay got it but
sitting with yourself there's no better
education yeah of like facing every
demon and it's all going to come out and
it's not going to be pretty mhm but then
there's there's things that happen on
the other side of it that are so
profound have you met most of your
demons I've met the demons that have
come out oh there may be more who knows
yeah okay well to be
continued